fabrice epelboin je rappelle que vous
êtes spécialiste des réseaux sociaux et
enseignant à sciences po paris et donc
comment est-ce que vous expliquer le
fait que youtube suspende sa chaîne à
donald trump
après twitter et facebook qu'il en fait
également comment on peut expliquer
cette boîte de pandore ouverte en
quelque sorte c'est la suite logique de
notre homme s'est fait des pâtes faut
remiser par l'ensemble des gaffes a
finalement google youtube sont les
derniers dans une très courte séquence
avoir des plates formes ise domaine
femmes tout le monde
la pire et de ses plateformes que ça
soit amazon google facebook twitter
comment alors est ce qu'on peut parler
d'une décision politique de la part des
gens du web des dégâts femmes
on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de dirigeants
politiques français qui se sont dits
choqués de cela de tous bords confondus
qu'ils soient pro ou entrer ou anti
trust 1 mais les dirigeants politiques
européens sont très conscients du
cultural tels qu'ils existent entre les
états unis et l'europe et se doute bien
que de telles décisions pourraient tout
à fait revenir à leur encontre demain
par ailleurs qui sont quand même très
inquiet de cette privatisation de la
justice et de ce pouvoir qui par des
entreprises qui sont plus tout à fait
des entreprises pas tout à fait des
états qui sont des formes hybrides qui
aujourd'hui ont un rôle politique
totalement dominant dans le monde
mais quel danger alors à l'avenir si on
peut considérer que les réseaux sociaux
s'imposant régulateur le danger c'est
une privatisation de la justice est une
privatisation totale du débat public sur
des plateformes qui seront de situation
monopolistique
donc c'est très clairement à une
privatisation de ce qu'ils étaient il ya
des démocraties et alors comment limiter
l'influencé de ces réseaux sociaux
quelles solutions trouvées juridiquement
écouter pour l'instant il ya deux
solutions qui se font jour dans le monde
il ya la solution américaine qui
clairement ne satisfait pas grand monde
qui consiste à privatiser la justice et
puis il ya des solutions qui ont été
adoptées en chine ou en russie qui
consiste à
finaliser ces plateformes pense à
alibaba qui même si je n'ai pas une
plateforme de réseau social a été
nationalisée de façon un peu violente ou
avec à l'équivalent russe de facebook
qui a été confisqué à son fondateur et
qui aujourd'hui sous la coupelle de
l'état russe
il reste à inventer peut-être une autre
solution de régulation mais pour
l'instant dans des loin on n'est même
pas capable de lever des impôts
vis-à-vis de ses acteurs en france aux
états unis le premier amendement
consacre la liberté d'expression les
réseaux sociaux se montre clairement au
dessus de la constitution américaine
c'est ça alors là les la liberté
d'expression n'est pas le plus absolu
l'appel à la sédition ne fait pas partie
des droits couverts par le premier
amendement douce c'est quelque chose de
tout à fait discutable
et puis localement typiquement en france
il n'ya rien comparable au premier
amendement
il y à une multitude de choses qui sont
parfaitement interdit en france comme
par exemple prenez le racisme et qui
sont parfaitement légale aux états unis
donc il ya besoin d'avoir une
application locale de la loi si tenté
que ces plateformes ne se met pas au
dessus des états pour l'instant elles
sont au dessus des états de facto donald
trump devrait s'exprimer ce soir ce
qu'il va aborder ce thème selon vous
qu'est peut-il dire que peut-il faire il
ne peut pas dire grand chose parce que
désormais il a un filtre de médias qui
lui sont extrêmement hostile et ne peut
plus faire grand chose parce que il
quittera pouvoir dans moins d'une
semaine
donc soyons clairs donald train dé plus
en position de faire grand chose
par contre ses militants les plus
hardcore sont eux dans une situation de
radicalisation extrême qui pourrait
mener à des débordements très inquiétant
merci beaucoup fabrice epelboin d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes spécialiste des réseaux
sociaux vous êtes également enseignant à
sciences po paris